and we're back with massive racha the
president of the german institute for
economic research and the former head of
international policy analysis at the ECB
so firstly what you take on the ECP's
handling of the crisis I think the ECB
has done rather well we still have a
year we still have a very stable Europe
would you say so I mean it plunged
against the dollar recently is that
stability its stability it's one at 110
roundabout at the moment that's not a
undervalued currency right i mean if you
if you think about it the country on
economy having such a deep crisis and
capitals still coming in and the
currency being relatively stable i think
that is a success story i think it
caught of could have got a lot worse
let's remember 2012 and mr. Draghi made
that promise we will do whatever it
takes a lot of people in Germany don't
like that he said that but fact is he
rescued really he avoided a much deeper
crisis in Europe because you just
mentioned Mario Draghi I mean how
political would you say has the ECB
become under Mario Draghi at the head
and what would be the alternatives
because a lot of people say the ECB is
no longer independent the ECB has been
pushed into a political role ever since
2008 because government said we don't
want to do enough or we don't want to
act we want to rely on the ECB it has
not been a choice by the ECB to have
that power and influence or financial
markets the ECB shouldn't have that
power it should be government's taking
the the you know that the activity and
really try to act and implement economic
policy so it's nothing the ECB should
want and ECB should focus really getting
back to its core mandate of price
stability and how can this be done and
be achieved I mean you also advise the
German government on economic issues
what are you telling them what should
they do we need a fundamentally new
architecture in Europe right we need
much closer cooperation we must prevent
that countries in the future make
economic policy mistakes spend too much
lag structural reforms so we need a
stronger political cooperation in europe
so the pressure will be taken off the
ECB and
cisions should be taken the political
rearm where they actually really belong
all right Massa faccia thank you very
much